geneviève dichamp bonjour bonjour
veyronnet merci nous accueillir à
nouveau au théâtre montansier à
versailles vous êtes la codirectrice de
cet endroit avec qui frédéric franck
voilà et écoutez quoi de neuf docteur
j'ai envie de vous dire la création de
l'avare de molière mise en scène par
jean luc martinet des avec jacques weber
dans le rôle d'harpagon voilà ça c'est
le scoop c'est le scoop de la jour du
mois de mars du mois de mars
donc en fait ils sont la création si une
création de montpensier absolument le 6
mars
voilà et nous jouons ici jusqu'au 14
mars d'accord donc huit représentations
avant une tournée de quarante dates en
france
d'accord ou terrier alors quand on dit
une création ça se passe comment toutes
les répétitions sont faites ici
répétition d'abord en studio de
répétition anouk ailleurs ailleurs
implantation du décor ici il ya trois
semaines on veut et répétitions à deux
ou trois services par jour depuis trois
semaines de trois services tv hier ça
veut dire deux fois ou trois fois quatre
heures de travail ça c'est un service
voilà d'accord bon alors tout à l'heure
on espère rattraper au vin attrapé
monsieur weber entre deux services
oisive dites moi donc cet avare donc
monsieur webber va jouer wagon
évidemment j'ai envie de vous demander
pourquoi molière à l'orne et loire
molière la sq n'a pas d'enjeu beaucoup
désolé mais là on sort de du misanthrope
si on peut dire avec michel fau mis en
scène et joué par michel fau et
notamment julie depardieu qui était un
grand succès d'ailleurs
voilà et là on réattaque à nouveau
molière avec la va donc tout ça alors
pourquoi molière pascal bonniere est
très d'actualité
oui toujours c'est une langue qui
aujourd'hui a une portée certaine dans
l'analyse des caractères et la manière
dont il dépeint le genre humain qui n'a
m'a tellement changé depuis le xviie est
par ailleurs les metteurs en scène sont
très différents et l'esthétique mise en
oeuvre par michel fau pour le
misanthrope et d'esthétique mise en
oeuvre par jean louis martinelli pour
laval n'ont rien de comparable c'est des
artistes qui ont des parcours très
différents
ouais et qui propose donc des oeuvres
très différente quand je dis proposer
des heures différentes
ça ne veut pas dire qu ils tordent les
oeuvres ça veut dire qu'ils les analyses
pour en donner vraiment
une présentation sur scène qui soit
conforme à notre sens de ce que
souhaitait molière quand il a décrit ces
situations du misanthrope ou d'harpagon
en navarre d'accord poussé à l'extrême
parce que si je me souviens bien michel
fau avait une mise en scène un décor
plutôt baroque des costumes plutôt
baroque assez flamboyant et la super
magnifique d'une couleur chatoyante et
qu'est ce que va nous proposer donc jean
louis martinelli du coup alors un
magnifique décor tout en bois qui
représente une maison avec acura jardin
des persiennes et le jour qui passe à
travers les persiennes donc un
magnifique décor en bois et des costumes
une esthétique contemporaine
d'accord il sera bien un billet un peu
mieux mais comment comment se fait
d'accord voilà donc on est sur des des
metteurs en scène avec des esthétiques
différentes mais des metteurs en scène
qui ont une vraie vision par rapport au
texte mais c'est ça qui nous intéresse
c'est de proposer des oeuvres avec une
vision et non pas une programmation qui
à la file proposerait des molières sans
ambition l'ambition ça veut dire
programmée des grands molière les grands
molière donc la barre évidemment fait
partie des grands molière et à la sas
adresse acquis aux scolaires aux enfants
et ça sera dans plusieurs avoir dans sa
vie
on peut voir plusieurs avoir dans sa vie
et on peut voir molière à tous les âges
donc nous on accueille effectivement
dans le cadre d'une politique
volontariste en direction des écoles on
accueille entre deux et trois classes
par soi même
mais tout le reste du public ce sont ces
le tout public
d'accord et quand vous dites à tous les
âges ça veut dire qu'on perçoit un
message différent selon l'âge à laquelle
on voit la pièce oui parce qu'un enfant
il va rire au hossein sur la nourriture
quand on dit qu'il faut manger pour
vivre et non pas vivre pour manger
il variera la scène de la cassette quand
il cherche son argent un adolescent il
va plus se ressentir les histoires de
transmission et notamment que harpagon
ne veut pas transmettre à ces
adolescents qui veulent eux rentrés dans
la vie est quelqu'un de plus âgé sera
plus sur comment moi je gère aussi ce
patrimoine opposition à tous les âges
molière et on peut entendre molière et
quand harpagon rendent sur selle est dit
aujourd'hui je plains ceux qui doivent
emprunter sa une résonance de toutes
races actuelle très actuel pour le
public et de noël donc finalement les
problématiques finalement n'ont pas
changé non parce que l'homme
la société évolue mais lyme est le même
et les caractéristiques et les défauts
et les qualités humaines
elles sont les mêmes d'accord bombe
écouter cette donne envie d'aller voir
revoir la var en plus avec jacques weber
qui n'est pas un hasard
auxquels on pense très spontanément
d'ailleurs mais c'est ça ça va jacques
weber est un bavard qui prend tous
d'accord c'est un ogre un ogre
d'accord je comprends hockey et
maintenant j'aimerais qu'on parle aussi
du futur festival du mot hier puisque
vous y participez bien évidemment et
j'aurais aimé savoir ce qui va se passer
alors ici déjà c'est le mois où il ya
ces deux camps à quand le mois molière
c'est du 1er juin au 30 juin
d'accord tout le mois de juin dans toute
la ville oui donc le montant sied
s'associent évidemment à cet événement
qui est menée par la ville en proposant
dans la salle des spectacles et
notamment des créations alors qu'elles
sont elles ces créations alors nous
recevrons une création qui est en ce
moment présenté à paris qu'on a
coproduit un marie tudor joué par
cristiana reali d'accord est présenté
actuellement la pépinière marie tudor 2
victor hugo très belle mise en scène de
ce rapport entre cette reine là on est
toujours dans classique on est dans le
classique mais un classique et vraiment
on va dire réinterpréter mais qui permet
d'entendre parfaitement le texte de
victor hugo
d'accord et puis nous accueillerons un
shakespeare mise en scène par hervé van
der molen beaucoup de bruit pour rien ok
et en plus
la moderne mais plus actuel on a eu ras
thomas fersen résidence de création
septembre qu'il était ici voilà qui est
parti à l'année dernière est venue qui
est passée la dernière avec un groupe
colas il sera seul en scène
oui il a donc été en résidence de
création au mois de septembre et il
viendra présenter les trois derniers
concerts de sa tournée ici alors
pourquoi thomas fersen oui pourquoi de
mauvaises ou dans la boue année comme
nous ils aiment beaucoup marie
antoinette
comme il a bien pris vie le pseudonyme
de l'amoureux de marie-antoinette voilà
bon mais écoutez samaya très varié très
riche ça donne vraiment envie d'écouter
merci geneviève on va les rejoindre
monsieur jacques weber dans salons et
dans sa loge
voilà à bientôt merci merci jacques
weber bonjour merci nous accueillir dans
votre loge au théâtre montansier vous
préparer à jouer la var dans une mise en
scène de jean louis martinelli et donc
je me demandais si vous étiez déjà venu
jouer ici dans ce terrain
je n'ai je suis venu et plusieurs fois
en tournée d'accord je crois que je joue
là contraire de valladoid
je crois que j'ai joué un spectacle seul
aussi en scène je crois ce que j'ai fait
pas mal vite on gagnait ce qui est vrai
on se souvient toujours les montants
siècle d'un bep vous savez très bien
c'est un des plus beaux théâtres
français est très agréable à jouer donc
je me souviens en tout cas jouer ici
mais j'ai bien connu voilà très bien et
alors quel est votre votre histoire
entre ce qui est une histoire
particulière entre vous et molière parce
que j'ai remarqué que deux des 73 vous
avez écrit ou juin spectacle sur jean
baptiste poquelin
après vous avez joué et mis en scène le
roman de monsieur molière
oui vous avez joué tactique le
misanthrope dose y en a énormément joué
bas j'ai pas de réponse spécifique à
donner si ce n'est que
j'ai une vraie passion d'abord pour le
théâtre classique que ce sont mes
racines nues pour que l'arbre
bourgeonner il faut les racines comme on
dit
et puis quand même c'est vrai que c'est
une chance dans une vie de pouvoir jouer
des rôles aussi importants
aussi force profond c'est nigma tic
toujours à découvrir
et puis moi j'ai la chance je suis un
des rares à les avoir joués tous plus de
300 400 fois donc comme le disait ce
trailer et un grand metteur en scène
c'est au bout de cinquante
représentations qu'on commençait à peu
près bien joué un rôle de 51 ans juste
mais c'est encore une phrase mais elle
compte dit beaucoup de choses quand vous
les cas vous avez vécu avec pendant 200
300 présentation ça cela ça devient
extrêmement intéressant et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui fait que j'ai une
somme de comment dirais-je de wii 2 je
me sens chez moi quoi je dirais pas que
je suis en pantoufles je me sens chez
moi a été mis à l'eau pour jouer molière
ouais d'accord et être qu'on peut faire
un parallèle avec cyrano par exemple
barres parallèles non c'est de la folie
comme vous c'est la nausée ma vie dans
ce cas là bas du zinc en tout cas si
vous savez que molière cyrano son
contemporain
ils font partie de ce que l'on appelait
le groupe des libertins éclairé ils sont
amis ils se connaissent bien
on dit même la pièce de rostand le dis
très clairement que molière se serait
inspiré d'une pièce de cyrano pour
écrire les forêts de scapin entre autres
un dock est vraiment une gémellité
on sera plus grand mais disons une
famille l'affinité extrêmement claires
les cas entre
cyrano qui est donc un personnage qui
existait bien évidemment et molière
d'accord mais comment vous abordez ce
une question bateau mais harpagon on
n'imagine pas du tout comme vous
physiquement par mois
bah oui oui l'a vu notamment dans auto
de cyrano et du coup bah ça fait partie
du travail d'acteur j'imagine wen
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que c'est à vous tout simplement en
étant respectueux du texte et de sa
formidable liberté est faux je crois que
contrairement à ce qu'il se dit il n'y a
pas de tradition occidentale du théâtre
français
il ya des mauvaises habitudes et l'avare
pâtissent souvent d'une espèce
d'archétypes définitive de la varde ne
lave pas réapparu juin voilà on peut
très souvent il a été joué et d'ailleurs
de jouer de façon magnifique par
conscience reebok est dit que denis
podalydès j'ai le siège en pâte
mais jean vila mais toujours une espèce
de steve est un peu petit un peu
maigrelet parce que havard b je connais
je connais deux grands personnes qui
sont atteintes de cette maladie qui sont
des gens qui peuvent me mesurer deux
mètres et avait pesé 150 kg et avoir les
âmes a dit avoir sa mère et moi
d'ailleurs bien au delà de bien au delà
de 2,7 fascination réelle qui là pour
l'argent il y à il y à il y a comme dans
tous les grands personnages de molière
quelque chose de beaucoup plus complexe
beaucoup plus humain c'est une caisse
qui beaucoup plus moderne par sa
structure beaucoup plus inventives
beaucoup plus folles beaucoup plus sains
aux légumes et a prise de risque qu'ont
ils imaginent canton dans l'image que
l'on en a et hermès - hébreu était mal
et voilà les autres les choses comme ça
non c'est quelque chose de c'est une
pièce réellement fascinante et beaucoup
plus encore une fois audacieuse qu'on me
qu'on ne le croit ok mais goûté on se
réjouit de pouvoir jouer nat merci voilà
ici voilà et navarre qui alla bien
sympathique ça fait très peur mais peut
plus croire en rien je crois que c'est
ça qui est intéressant c'est que oui
plus vous le fait d'ailleurs la flèche
le décrit comme ça c'est un type qui a
l'air très gentil très marrant mais dès
qu'il s'agit de deux touchés à son
domaine à son noyau
il ya beaucoup de temps comme ça donc
plus quoi ok mais sur ceux à bientôt et
merci beaucoup d'univers